vous regardez le lac d'annecy
et vous imaginez que ce plan d'eau est
au centre une zone de loisir idéal n'est
pas tellement tort mais si vous ouvrez
un autre dossier celui de l'animation
culturelle des loisirs vous découvrez
avec anxiété que cela ne peut suffire à
toute l'agglomération annécienne qui
compte actuellement près de 90 mille
habitants avec une population très jeune
la moitié a moins de 30 ans et dont le
dos de croissance est très élevé compte
tenu de ces données succincte
penchez-vous davantage sur votre dossier
alors vous serez surpris de découvrir un
conservatoire musique qu'ils possèdent
chose rare en france des cours de
guitare de clavecin et de danse dans
cette ville
la culture traditionnelle est en pleine
évolution
en second de pradines 2
fait qu'en seconde tenez cette
bibliothèque la plus grande de la ville
possède une section enfants 1600 abonnés
le prêt à domicile
l'abonnement coûte de francs par an
vous vous demandez si cette ville fait
mieux encore si l'on est conscient que
la culture n'est pas l'apanage de
quelques initiés alors que faites vous
vous allez découvrir les maisons de
jeunes
il y en a deux à annecy avec chacune
deux mille cinq cents adhérents environ
est ce suffisant si l'on songe aux
besoins de milliers de jeunes sans
oublier les adultes
à tel point que ces millions de jeunes
se transforment actuellement en maison
ouverte à tous avec des activités très
vague
vous êtes songeur devant l'animation
culturelle de ces maisons écoutez cette
réponse une parmi tant d'autres celle de
la directrice de la mjc des marquises à
une activité culturelle dans une maison
des chaînes de la culture ça ne doit pas
être uniquement de la diffusion
culturelle mais les activités doivent
culturelles doivent être comme des
activités sportives ou des activités
d'expression où chacun doit prendre des
responsabilités
vous constatez très rapidement que ces
maisons de jeunes sont ouvertes aux
enfants étudiants et aux adultes avec de
nouvelles activités basées sur des
méthodes actives qui donne à tous une
très grande liberté d'expression un
autre exemple
cet atelier d'enfants animée par deux
comédiens du théâtre populaire de savoir
un autre élément à verser au dossier
nous essayons de susciter l'imagination
de l'enfant c'est à dire que nous nous
sommes comédien et nous leur proposons
des techniques d'un dramatique si vous
voulez c'est à dire expression
corporelle rythmique dance qui leur
permet de ces de s'exprimer et de
développer leur imagination à travers
ces techniques une autre étape est
franchie c'est sans doute la seule ville
en france qu'ils recherchaient une
certaine efficacité en organisant ses
activités culturelles dans un premier
temps qu'aux statham si la création d'un
bureau technique qui permet une
meilleure action culturelle daniel sont
unis
est-ce que c'est suffisant parce que
c'est le premier pas nous avons créé ici
dans ses locaux une agence technique qui
doit régler un certain nombre de
problèmes techniques communs aux
associations c'est donc des problèmes de
billetterie d'affichage d'informations
journal etc et leur et c'est pour ça
toutes les associations ou non mais
c'est à dire que tout seul qui ont voulu
une toutes les actions culturelles mais
aussi les comités d'entreprise et aussi
les différents groupements de cette
ville qui désirez entrer dans cette
démarche
finalement et pu le faire et aujourd'hui
par exemple on peut constater le des
groupements d'enfants sont venus au
théâtre ainsi assister au spectacle
alors là c'est à paul est un peu
différent puisque là c'est le groupe
d'accent théâtrale qui en quelque sorte
à organiser ses spectacles enfants
depuis maintenant un an est en quelque
sorte lagence technique intervient sur
le plan humain aux produits organisation
bien sûr direz vous ce bureau fonctionne
mais dans quel esprit
cette culture est elle accessible à tous
en at-on les moyens
pierre jacquet de la commission
culturelle de la ville d'al ci répond à
cette question
d'abord les besoins sont très grands
puisqu'il ya environ 47% la population
active composée d'ouvriers sur les
ouvriers qui en 20 parties viennent des
campagnes il ya beaucoup de travailleurs
étrangers également
et comme le disait sans unis tout à
l'heure c'est clair qu'au niveau de
l'école on peut arriver à toucher tout
le monde
les comités d'entreprise aussi le
permettre mais alors quand il s'agit de
les toucher et les moyens dont vous
parlez il faudrait ici développé toute
une dialectique d'action culturelle or
c'est pas à la ville en tant que tel de
mettre sur pied des organismes
municipaux qui serait chargée de les
extraire des ouvriers leur comité
d'entreprise ghorzi nos corps syndicats
mais il faut que ce soit les gens
intéressés
en premier lieu les organiser les
syndicats et les comités d'entreprise
mais aussi les organiser
les inorganisés qu'ils puissent ensemble
collaborer à une action culturelle qui
les concernent directement
et nous avons tenté de trouver une
structure originale qui répondent aux
besoins spécifiques de cette huile non
seulement par les besoins exprimés mais
aussi par les besoins qui pourront
s'exprimer dans l'avenir démystifier la
culture n'est ce pas le but de la
véritable animation et danse et c'est
déjà s'exprimer
dans les structures qu'on met en place
on veut rien n'est terminé
c'est des structures qu'ils se
détermineront au fur et à mesure qui
fait que s'il n'y a plus de besoins bas
une section culturelle clavera et s'il
ya des nouveaux besoins ça ça
s'épanouira se sont formidables et que
nous sur le plan jazz en fait une
expérience qui est peut-être unique dans
l'histoire du jazz al fahm cohabitent
même transalpins et on peut pas
expliquer ça en quelques minutes